hello everyone a lot of you have
requested this game already
well maybe even a match to show a couple
of games Garry Kasparov vs. deep blue
before I show you the game and tell you
a little bit about this match I just
wanted you to know that the Amazon gift
cards have been sent away and that the
championship chess set is also on its
way to Luca which so I think that takes
care of the prizes and once again
congratulations to the winners of the
giveaway now on to this match Kasparov
played two matches against the IBM's
deep blue one in 1996 and one in 1997
the one in 1996 was play played in
Philadelphia and it's considered not to
be deep blue it's considered to be deep
thought because the one in 97 was like
an upgrade so that one is called deep
blue and Kasparov won the match in 1996
with a result of 42 and out of those six
games
casparo offered a draw in game 5 and
deep blue refused what he thought refree
refused the draw so casparo managed to
win Game five with the black pieces and
then of course won Game six with the
white pieces so it was a pretty clean
victory for four against two
you know against the supercomputer and
then IBM well requested a rematch in
1997 this was the upgraded to be blue
and unlike for the first match in 1996
work as part of lost the first game in
1997 in in round 1 Kasparov won the
first game then the blue won the second
game then three games were drawn and the
result is true and I have two and a half
and this is game six so let's see this
historic Game six and why do I say
historic because this 1997 match Garry
Kasparov versus the blue is the first
time in history that a computer managed
to win a match against a reigning World
Chess Champion so let's see this beauty
deep blue has the white pieces and she
it he whatever you want to call it it
plays efore we have c6 d4 and d5 in Game
four of this match
as part of try the d6 but here he was
for d5 Knight to c3 we have D captures
on e4 Knight captures on e4 and the
Knight to d7 Kasparov goes for the
carpet variation we have Knight to g5
now Knight to G to f6 Bishop to d3
Kaspar who goes east six and Knight 1 to
F 3 and here Kasparov has a lot of
options to go for he can go for Bishop
to d6 he can go for Queen to c7 he can't
even go to for something like Bishop to
b4 check but Kasparov played a move that
I'm pretty sure he wouldn't play against
a human player he played h6 thinking
that there is no way that well the data
computer will take advantage of this and
sacrifice a piece but that's exactly
what happened in this position who
played Knight captures on e6 and
Kasparov played the Queen to e7 of
course you don't
you don't want to capture F captures on
e6 you get Bishop to g6 check and after
came to these seven Bishop to f4 and
your position is extremely hard to play
you can't develop any of the pieces the
rooks are staying where they are this
Bishop can't go anywhere so this would
be very pleasant for white so after
Knight captures on e6 Kasparov played
Queen to e7
now pinning this Knight deep blue now
castles and we have F captures on e7 of
course you don't want to capture it with
the Queen unfortunately we have to mess
up your pawn structure because Queenie 6
and then rocky 1 so after castles
Kasparov played F captures on e6 and now
of course he had to allow Bishop to g6
check came to d8 and now Bishop to f4
now putting his bishop on this beautiful
diagonal guarding c7 and not allowing
the King to leave the center of the
board
we have b5 by Kasparov I'm going for
some Bishop e7 maybe Bishop e6 area and
trying to get the king somewhere to the
Queen side to a safe place
a4 deep blue immediately wants to bust
open the Queen side pawn structure
bishop the beast
and I wrote the e one deep blue is
preparing Bishop to f5 to pin this pawn
on e6 we have Knight to d5 now attacking
the bishop on f4 Bishop to g3 of course
the blue doesn't want to give up this
powerful Bishop King to see it now by
Kasparov and we have a captures on b5
still capture some b5 and Queen to d3
now it's threatening to capture this b5
phone and here Kasparov played Bishop to
c6 maybe maybe a maybe a better idea was
something like Knights to c7 but then
you get a rope to a three rookies coming
to c3 and this will be very very hard to
play for black this Bishop is still
lying c7 so instead Kasparov after Queen
to d3 played Bishop to c6 and now Bishop
Bishop to f5 deep blue pins this pawn
and the power of decides to give up the
Queen for Bishop and the rook he played
he captures on f5 given up his queen he
could have played something like night
two before but this doesn't really go in
his favor okay this does give you a
tempo on the Queen but now not a queen
to c3 you're threatening you're
threatening the night a frightening the
bishop with the Queen after the knight
moves the e6 pawn is still attacked and
after something like a five rock
captures on e6 and if you want to play
something like Queen to d8 to try and
save everything rook captures on c6 if
you capture a night cap for c6 Queen C
sex leads to checkmate Queen c7 Queen
captures on c7 and after Oh captors in
c6 if you play King - b7 then Bishop 34
and you're you're losing this game very
hard so after Bishop to a5 Kasparov
decided not to go for any of this he
played he captures on f5 Road captors on
e7 by deep blue and Albert of captures
on e7 so okay Kasparov has a rook and
two pieces for the Queen
but here this is more 19 the blue plays
c4 and in this position and move c4
Casper resigns the game the world
champion decides that in this last game
there is there is no chance for him to
continue this fight if he managed to to
draw this game it would you know the end
result in a match would be a draw he
wouldn't lose the match because in the
end he lost the match three and a half
to two and a half but what happens now
well if something like D captures and c4
then we Queen captures and c4
threatening the bishop here and after
nice to be for protecting the bishop
rook to e1 not threatening to grab the
bishop and then the night and after
something like rook to e8 you simply
grab it Rock capture screen captures
now we're threatening the rook on e7
also ideas like Queen a5 - Queen c7
checkmate are here so after something
like King to d8 you can always play
Bishop to h4 pinning the rook g5 Knight
captures H captures Bishop captures this
rook is you know gonna be captured with
Czech and Kasparov decided not not to go
for any of this
so after c4 he decided to forfeit the
game and the blue was the winner of the
1997 match and of course Kasparov was a
very angry he said that there is no way
that that a computer can play a game
like this such a highly tactical game
you know to decide I get to give up a
piece computers in those days were
extremely materialistic so because part
of you know said that the deep-blue was
probably aided by other grandmasters
which is you know to be expected I guess
some some people even say that IBM had
Bobby Fischer that Bobby Fischer was
giving them moves for IBM to play you
know some some chess fun so yeah that's
the game you requested the Garry
Kasparov versus deep blue if you want to
see any other games from the
97 or the 1996 match just writes
something you know in that fashion in
the comment section I would like to
thank Eric Wilkinson Boulevard leaves da
Costa Vieira and Antonio Cory for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
I think all for watching and I will see
you soon